hello everybody I'm Jesse waters along
with Emily campano Juan Williams Kennedy
and Greg it's five o'clock in New York
City and this is the five
[Music]
I was happy to see on the front page of
the New York Times for the first time
where they were talking about spying and
they were talking about spying on my
campaign it's absurd bigger than
Watergate as far as I'm concerned
President Trump calling a new report
that his campaign was spied on bigger
than Watergate as Democrats in the media
continue to eat crow the New York Times
exposing just how far the spying went
during the summer of 2016 the FBI sent
an undercover female investigator to
meet then Trump aids Papadopoulos at a
London bar she reportedly then asked him
if the Trump campaign was working with
Russia and Papadopoulos says the young
informant even tried to seduce him I won
and I met with her and she was very
suggestive as you can understand younger
you know very flirtatious and I right
away understood that this wasn't a
Cambridge assistant and was trying to do
two things one to extract information
about my professional connections in the
Middle East and two to see if I had any
information that she could potentially
extract for me about Trump in Russia
which of course is nonsense when the New
York Times suggested in their reporting
today that the British were were told of
this operation I believe the British
actually were actively spying on me as
well and president Trump thinks he knows
who started the whole thing I think is
corrupt as hell and I think what's
happened between Comey and McCabe and
Brennan and all of these people I think
that he did a terrible job I would say
he probably led some kind of an effort
the words spying has been used he
probably was one of the people leading
the effort on spying and the media is
once again looking foolish let's take a
quick trip down memory lane when they
trashed Trump for daring to suggest that
there was fine
president Trump has a new favorite word
and every time he uses it he is lying
and that is the word spy the president
is tweeting in high gear he wants you to
believe that his campaign was spied on
and it's one of the worst things that
we've ever seen from government the
notion that somehow the FBI implanted
planted
someone in
the campaign to spy on the campaign is
just not true and just not true all
right so Greg the media's been wrong
about the dossier about collusion and
now they've been wrong about spying but
I know you want to talk about the honey
trap probably I probably don't know I
want to say though that there has been
one ôs of rightness and I believe it's
called the 505 didn't write the entire
so I have the five by the way I did
enjoy I didn't enjoy him saying bigger
than Watergate because that was the
basically throwing it back at everybody
saying that collusion was bigger than
Watergate that's like saying you know
just say no while smoking a joint you
know it was his way of mocking everybody
for the past two years the media's gonna
have to play this down because they've
been wrong for what three years have
been chasing the wrong story the whole
time they're like the reverse Columbo
right it's like they always cat they
never catch the bad guy they always
catch the wrong guy so they're gonna
have to continue this narrative because
it's too humiliating so they're gonna
shout about Magan and they're gonna
shout about getting Muller because they
can't admit that for so long
they were chasing the wrong no it is
it's like a great episode of law and
order you know how there's always a
surprise at the end a surprise twist but
it's always the architect you know that
kills the person in this case it's like
though the rich executive is innocent
that's maybe Columbo is is the bad guy
yeah
think about this unbelievable they've
spied on a presidential campaign they've
tried to cover it up and whan has been
wrong about the whole thing
this is like a drunkards convention you
guys are so often - I know it's Friday
but it's not Friday night yet so as the
New York Times fake news what your what
your fake news impact you said the FBI
implanted somebody in the campaign how
crazy is this but you just go on air so
if you sent a paid informant overseas to
entrap someone yeah they were doing
their job their job is to check and see
if a foreign nation was interfering in
an American election they said someone
over there because Papadopoulos had told
people yeah oh yeah and Russia's
providing information the DA police that
I think another informant I don't know
who told them but that's what what does
FBI stand for Bureau of Investigation
they didn't come to any conclusion they
were protecting America and you make
this that's like Trump
I guess you're reiterating Trump's
points and you just say oh yeah that
that means there's fine there's no it's
just not spoil yeah now it's paid
informants overseas and I love that
somehow changing the definition of words
is going to make problems go away and I
really hope there are journalists who
investigate this story thoroughly so it
doesn't happen again
you have you have 25 people on the
Democrat side who wanted this job they
have this amount of power that they can
do the same thing because the person
they hate the most in the world the
person that they who's who's ever
existed that person is the President of
the United States and arguably has the
exact same power within his domain and
can do the same thing that the FBI and
CIA did under the Obama administration
they better get to the bottom of the
story and they better make damn sure
that there are some massive structural
changes that have been made yet power
has been abused and I think in my
opinion this is the New York Times and
the intelligence community getting out
in front of what they see is an IG
report coming out it's going to be
damning that is exactly the reason why
the Democrats in the media are attacking
all of this and
especially AG barn is testimony yeah
they're trying to undermine his
credibility so that when the IG report
comes out and proves the FBI and CIA
overreached and overstepped its
government bounds it will be proven in
it and that is why everyone in those two
buildings or from those buildings like
Comey are terrified and I want to tell
you that that by the way yeah and the
reason why it's such a big deal it's not
just to this spine it's the spine also
in conjunction with the fact that there
was no defensive briefing of the Trump
then campaign that is what proves that
our intelligence agencies were deployed
and armed against then-candidate Trump
if at the time they thought the campaign
had been compromised in some way and
that there were people within the
campaign that were compromised they
would have briefed the president they
would have briefed the venn candidate
but they didn't which means that they
thought he was or wanted him to be the
Russian asset junk shared with a lot of
defensive it was a general briefing but
Emily they didn't know so they're trying
to find out if Russia in fact has put
some kind of asset inside the campaign
so they don't want to blow themselves up
so they are making a request we have
eight intelligence agencies plus the
Muller report that say Russia interfered
in 2016 campaign we have Jim Comey who
is FBI director never said it were to us
the American people about the fact that
there was a counterintelligence
operation aimed at discovering whether
or not Russia was somehow hidden inside
the Trump campaign he did that to
Hillary Clinton he protected this
president James Comey protected the word
if he had put out the word toward the
end of the campaign the FBI had an
active investigation into where the
rusher had some embedded assets inside
the truck and it would have devastated
so they cared more about politics than
national security what's National
Security because he didn't want to
interfere with the politics of it right
stay out of the politics can we just it
would be wise at this point after all
this time to just step back and take a
look at what's happening right now this
week you're seeing a lot of narratives
collapsing you're seeing for the molar
reports out it's not what you wanted I
understand that's over meanwhile we're
gonna talk about this in the next block
Trump's doing pretty good and you hate
Trump's guts that's another narrative
that's collapsing my advice is I think
the Democrats and the media should take
a timeout a vacation because this is not
going well for you so you have the
greatest economy probably in modern
history
you're gonna you're watching
unemployment numbers like you've never
seen for Hispanics and for women this is
an incredible time to be alive and you
are so mad that life is good
there's something wrong with you that's
why the president is talking to Putin
kid wonder why good news makes you sad
good news makes me have you should
wonder why closed eyes you don't see
anything socialist when it comes to the
economy they're all your eyes to these
numbers and how to compound it and make
it even better than it is yeah it's not
the message one person who's running for
president on the Democrat side
particularly one of a progressive stripe
who's talking about using this good
economic data and making it even better
that's in fact what exactly what
Elizabeth Warren they're all saying
they've got to do better for the middle
class in fact Biden gave a speech do you
think no one heard I think there is 200
people that showed up all right we're
gonna do that next one